[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد الى مناقشه الملف الثاني
اعلن رايس الامريكي والسابق دونالد ترامب
انه سيتم توقيفه يوم الثلاثاء داعيا
انصاره الى التظاهر وذلك تحسب الاحتمال
توجيه تهم اليه في قضيه دفع اموال نجمه
اباحيه قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2016
وذلك مقابل صمتها حيل علاقه تزعم انها
اقامتها معه قبل سنواته وكتب ترامب في
حسابه على منصه الاجتماعيه تروس روشل كتب
انه سيجري او سيجري توقيفه قائلا لانصاره
تظاهروا استعيدوا بلدنا كما تهم ترامب في
منشوره مكتب المدعي العام لمنطقه منهاتن
بانه فاسد واصرت مره اخرى على انه لم
يرتكب اي جريمه وذكر اتباعه بان المحكمه
تم تمويلها بشكل كبير من قبل الملياردير
الليبرالي جورج سوروس ولم يقدم ترامب اي
تفاصيل عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حول
كيفيه معرفه بالاعتقال المتوقع ولكن
محاميته سوزان نيشيلس قالت ان منشوره
استند الى تقارير اخباريه
ساعتقل يوم الثلاثاء
المدعي العام في مرهتن لن نتسامح مع
محاولات ترهيب المحققين
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي المدعي العام
في منهج يسيء استخدام السلطه ويسعى
لانتقام سياسي من ترامب ايلون ماسك اذا تم
اعتقال ترامب فانه سيحقق فوزا ساحقا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
جمهوريون خطط اعتقال ترامب انتقام سياسي
اداره شرطه نيويورك نحن في حاله تاهب
واستعداد لمواجهه اي احتجاجات محتمله على
خلفيه نداء ترامب لمناصريه بالتظاهر
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك
من واشنطن كذلك ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا
مع الاستاذه ايهاب استاذ ايهاب خلينا نتفق
اولا ثلاثتنا بانه هذا الموضوع هو موضوع
قانوني اخلاقي مذكره اعتقال يقال بانه على
خلفيه قضيه تتعلق بموضوع او ملف
القضيه مع الفتاه الاباحيه ولكن يطرح سؤال
وكانه هناك توجه لتسييس هذه القضيه وسؤال
مطروح هو من يسعى لذلك ترامب بدعوته
لانصاره للخروج واستخدام شعارات انقذوا
البلاد الى اخره ام من يسيس هذه القضيه هو
من يرفض ترشح ترامب للانتخابات القادمه
نعم اهلا بحضرتك واهلا استاذ بشار وبكل ال
المشاهدين يعني هذه اولا قضيه قديمه جديده
ولا جديده فيها سيكون من وجهه نظري
الشخصيه لان يعني اعتقد انها ستكون في
نهايه المطاف مسيسه بشكل كبير لماذا يقول
ذلك اولا هو رجل لا يحاسب بسبب علاقته مع
هذه السيده
ستور ميدانيز كما تسمى
وانما هو اذا ما سيحاكم فهو سيحاكم على
فكره انه حاول اسكاتها بمبلغ مالي هذه
التهمه موجهه للرئيس دونالد ترامب منذ
اكثر من ست سنوات ولم يثبت عليه حتى
اللحظه اي شيء لذلك انا اقول هناك لن يكون
اي شيء جديد بل بالعكس هي تاتي في توقيت
من الممكن ان تثير بلبله سياسيه هذه
البلبله السياسيه كما ذكر الى الماسك
ستكون في مصلحه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لانه بكل تاكيد سيخرج منها منتصرا
طبقا لما اشاهده الان من معطيات انا لا
اقول هذا هباء ولكن من المعطيات التي
نشاهدها في العمل السياسي الامريكي وفي
القانون الامريكي وفي طول مده هذه
الاتهامات دون اي ادله حقيقيه حتى اللحظه
الرئيس زون ترامب يبدو انه سيخرج قويا
وسيكون كما قال الى الماسك مرشحا لاكتساح
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه وخصومه
السياسيين يعلمون ذلك ولكن اعتقد اذا كانت
القضيه مسيسه فعلا وسيكون من الغباء
السياسي محاوله اسقاط الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب من محاوله خوله الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بهذه الطريقه الساذجه القديمه
جدا التي لم تحقق اي شيء منذ ست سنوات
سؤال اخر استاذ ايهاب سانقول له استاذ
بشار هل يمكن ان يكون ترامب نفسه وراء
تفجير هذه القضيه في هذا التوقيت
بالفعل هذا السؤال مطروح يعني اي صحفي
يفكر بيعطي الحره بدون اواقف مسبقه سيطرح
هذا السؤال ولكن اعتقد ان الارجح هو انه
تمكن من الحصول على ما سماه الليجو ليكس
بمعنى هذه التسريبات غير قانونيه
كان من الذكاء السياسي والاعلامي وقد
اشتهر بالتعامل بحسن التعامل واجاده
التعامل مع الاعلام الامريكي بانه كان
سباقا وهذا ما اربك المشهد ونرى هذه ردود
الفعل التي تتوالى من الحزبين الجمهور
والديمقراطي حتى الفئه المستقله او
المتارجحه التي صدمها ان يتعرض رئيس سابق
الى خطر بانه يصبح
بان يتم كلبشته وليس فقط توجيه الاتهام
سيقوم بالاجراءات المتعارف عليها بتبصيمه
بمعنى ان يضع بصماته على ضمن الاجراءات
وهنا دخلت اشكاليه مثيره بالفعل من ناحيه
السياسيه والاعلاميه انه لديه حرس رئاسي
ما زال يتمتع في ذلك وهنا تتداخل
الصلاحيات من الذي سيسلم من وهل سيكون
هناك فيما لو تم هذا المشهد بالفعل هذه
الصوره الصادمه اللي الراي العام العالمي
وليس فقط الامريكي بان ترى الرئيس ترامب
الرئيس السابق الولايات المتحده العظمى
القوه العظمى في العالم الوحيده في العالم
تكون في مشهد كما رايناه لي زعماء من
الشرق الاوسط وامريكا اللاتينيه هذا طبعا
يشكل صدمه وقد قيل حتى الان بانه لم يصدر
عن ادعاء منهات اي شيء يفيد بان ذلك
ايضا الدرس وانه مرشح
ولكن الاستاذ بشار هل افهم من حضرتك بانه
هذه الهواجس او هذه المخاوف قد تضعف شعبيه
ترامب لانه اعتقد لست وحدك من يفكر فيها
هناك شق كبير يفكر في هذا الموضوع ويتصور
صوره رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مكبل فهل يمكن ان تضعفه هكذا صوره
كل الاستطاعات مع اني انا لا اؤمن شخصيا
بالاستطلاعات وراينا فشلها الكبير ب 2016
ولحد كبير ايضا ب 2020 ولكن حتى الان
الصوره العامه في داخل الحزب الجمهوري بان
شعبيته صارت اكثر قوه
واكتسبت حملته الرئاسيه اكثر زخما لان
عندما استخدم عباره تيك
اورنيشن هذا نفس العباره التي استخدمها في
الخطاب ما قبل الاقتحام المؤسف للكونغرس
وطبعا الان وجدنا الكثير من الفضائح
الاعلاميه المتعلقه بالفيديوهات التي
اطلقت هو يربط الامور هذه بعضها ببعض
والطب الاخر الحزب الديمقراطي يعلم انه
محرج جدا هذه الصوره حتى للحزب لماذا وهنا
التوقيت الحساس لان تم تسريب هذه تم تس
هذه الانباء بعد يوم واحد من قيام المسؤول
اللجنه المتخصصه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
في الرقابه بالكشف عن بيانات مصرفيه
للرئيس بايدن وللحقيقه جيمس
الراحل بو بايدن الذي توفي بسبب السرطان
وهذا الامر اضافه لشخصيه رابعه لم يكشف
عنها عندما يقال ان لديهم اكثر ملايين
دولارات استقبلوها من الصين من شركه عليها
علامات استفهام فهذا التوقيت يشير الى انه
بالفعل كما اشرتم في المقدمه هذا انتقام
سياسي او حتى الطفل تتحدث عن التوقيت ولكن
قد نتحدث كذلك عن امكانيه بروز ادله استاذ
ايهاب تحدثنا منذ قليل عن الشقه الشعبي
للموضوع وكيف ينظر الامريكيون لهكذا
تطورات ولكن قانونا اذا ما سلمنا جدلا
بامكانيه ان تتوفر في هذه دلالات
ودلائل جديده الى اي مدى هذا الموضوع قادر
ان يعطل مسيره راب نحو كرسي الترشح قبل
كرسي رئاسه
يعني شوفي حضرتك هناك
اجراءات في القانون الامريكي من الممكن ان
يطول امادها وتستغرق على اقل تقدير عام
حتى يكون بمقدور الادعاء في منهات
توجيه تهمه حقيقيه مبنيه على ادله قويه
تصل لحد الادانه للرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب هذه المده الطويله ربما تصيب حمله
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اذا استكمل
ترشحه لمحاوله نيل
الترشح من الانتخاب الانتخاب من الحزب
الجمهوري من الممكن ان تصيب هذه الحمله في
مقتل بمعنى ان تصدر
الاتهامات
والادانه في منتصف الحمله ربما هذا يحدث
ربما قبل الحمله الانتخابيه اتحدث اذا ما
فاز
بجوله الانتخابات الداخليه في الحزب
الجمهوري وذهب الى محاوله الترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه وجمع المرشحه
الديمقراطي عندئذ هل هذا جائز هل هذا قائم
نعم هو قائم لكن لنفترض ان هناك ادله ادله
تدين الرئيس دونالد ترامب لمحاوله تقديم
رشوه انجاز التعبير هي هذه السيده هل
الادانه ستكون كافيه فقط للاطاحه به من
الانتخابات لن تكون كافيه لانه سيظل
يستطيع ان يترشح لان الادانه هناك استئناف
على هذه الادانه ويستطيع ان يبرئ ساحته
ايضا وبالتالي ستكون الامور صعبه جدا
استاذ ايهاب لما نقرا تصريحات ترامب
الاخيره انقذوا البلاد الى مذالك البعض
سيقول بانه يمتلك بعض المعلومات التي لم
ينشرها بعد او منعته محاميته من نشرها
وبالتالي قد يكون هناك شيء فعلي
او كيف يفسر دعوته بانقاذ البلاد
وهذا المستوى من الشعارات ولا شيء في
الملف
هو محاوله من الرئيس دونالد ترامب ان يجد
قاعده شعبيه تسانده في هذا المعترك
السياسي كما يعتقد انه مسيس
لمحاوله ثني السلطات من مغبه القيام باي
فعل يحسب عليهم ويحسب ضدهم ويكون لمصلحه
الرئيس هي محاوله من الرئيس دونالد ترامب
ان يكون الشعب الامريكي المحب له ملتف
حوله في هذه القضيه بدلا من ان ينتظر ان
تكون هناك اتهامات وعمليه القاء قبضه ومن
ثم يقوم بالشحن المواطنين
من الان واعتقد ربما هذا سيكون امر مهم
جدا
لجعل اي محقق يفكر في عمليه اعتقال الرئيس
سبق دونالد ترامب كي يفكر مرتين بدل مره
صحيح هو مهم وقد يكون خطير كذلك
ستبقى او يبقى هذا الملف للمتابعه اود
شكرا لكم بش
الكاتب المحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن دائما
ايهاب عباس المحلله السياسي شكرا لكما